c'est une nouvelle polémique qui une
fois encore concerne le concours miss
france
cette fois ci c'est au sujet du poids
des candidates que les esprits
s'échauffent il ya quelques jours
amandine bio une jeune femme qui
concourait au titre de miss auvergne
était venu sur le plateau de thé pmp
pour nous faire part de l'injustice dont
elle se disait victime où elle son
éviction du concours était due sans
doute à sa taille 42 alors qu'elle avait
participé à la journée de préparation le
soir même elle avait reçu un email
lui indiquant qu'elle ne faisait plus
partie du concours qui ce n'est pas à
cause de mon poids et pour quelle raison
on m'a fait comprendre que comparé aux
autres filles je passerai pour un boudin
elle aurait également entendu de façon
officieuse que c'est bien là la raison
de son éviction une personne du comité
lui aurait confié une très jolie et très
jolie tête mais le corps ne passe pas
la déléguée départementale de haute
loire avait expliqué pour se justifier
qu'amandine biou peser 8 kg de plus lors
de son élection les personnes qui ont
voté pour elle ont vu en maillot de bain
en robe de soirée les spectateurs ne
juge pas son poids mais la personne qui
allait une défense qui n'a pas tout à
fait convaincu aujourd'hui c'est sylvie
tellier la présidente du comité miss
france qui a décidé de prendre la parole
pour calmer la polémique
avant toute chose s'il vitelli précise
que la jeune femme n'avait aucune raison
d'être admises d'office au concours si
elle insiste que le fait qu'aucune
candidate n'est peser elle précise tout
de même sa pensée cela reste un concours
de beauté il y à des critères physiques
mais pas seulement on juge aussi
l'élégance la culture générale
il y as énormément de critères si elle
n'a pas gagné l'élection locale c'est
que le public ne l'a pas choisie avant
de lâcher une phrase pour le moins
explicite peut-être que le public
français n'est pas prêt à élire une
jeune femme qui fait 1 46 ou plus ce
soir
amandine bio est en plateau avec nous
pour réagir à cette polémique alors
selon vous miss france
un concours grosso fob alors bonsoir
amandine merci d'être avec nous
[Applaudissements]
étudiante en marketing allait bien dans
son corps avec sa taille 42 c'est ce
qu'elle dit elle a voulu se présenter
pour son papa qui rêvait de la voir se
présenter elle a refusé de faire une
taille 38 car elle voulait s'assumer et
casser les codes et le concours miss
france l'a refusée c'est ça mon dit tu
as fais tout à fait c'est fou que ça
quand même
c'est dingue soigner parce que non mais
franchement parce que non ce qui se
passe c'est que sylvie tellier a eu
20/20 castaldi au téléphone c'était
vendredi et elle dit qu'il n'y a pas du
tout ce critère de poids ni de taille
mais en fait ce qui est grave pour
amener ses gambettes elle l a fait
toutes les étapes à la défilé en maillot
de bain elle était là elle termine
deuxième il y en eut dit rien et au
moment où elle espère aller jusqu'au
bout et 10 ballons il ya un problème
et pour le coup strange et du côté des
oui effectivement c'est grosse pomme si
70 des choses dès le début on dit voilà
pour red bull france faut être comme ci
comme ça il n'y a pas de problème c'est
ça la met là on dit rien et on la lui
car son rêve
moi je leur accord je vais vous dire
alors normalement d'ailleurs amandine
doit être là où on peut vous décalez
d'assurer les a menés là parce que
regarder je vous le dis la réponse de
sylvie tellier dans tpm paix ouvert à
tous étaient vendredi regarde alors
c'est différent c'est la paix c'est le
vtc n'avait remporté le concours en
aucun cas c'est koné qui sélectionne les
filles c'est très bien alors j'avais un
truc à répondre à ça m'ont dit vous avez
vous pouvez répondre à sylvie tellier
ben oui parce que ben en fait c'est un
tissu de mensonges tout simplement parce
que rien n'est inscrit dans le contrat
seule la taille est rédhibitoire donc
s'ils auraient marqué sur un contrat
qu'il fallait rentrer dans une taille 38
maximum moi même je me serais pas
inscrits d'accord mais déjà on est venu
me chercher
si on est venu me chercher donc ceux qui
savent et c'est très bien la personne
qui est telle qu'elle est totalement
faisait pas 38 way and en chine car vous
avez dit fille comme ça alors je vous
dis on s'intéressait aux critères
obligatoires imposées par le comité miss
france
faut être deux né de sexe féminin ouais
donc pas
donc voilà je peux pas y aller française
s'est beaucoup à ce qu'on contre 18 et
24 ans et la dernière année pour vous
mais ça voilà est célibataire mesure au
minimum à mettre 60 disent pas de
tatouage visible et piercings possède un
casier un casier judiciaire vierge pâtir
au gie plastique ne pas avoir participé
à des séances photos captation
audiovisuelle dans lesquelles la
candidate apparaîtrait totalement ou
partiellement dénudée mais il n'y a rien
du tout qui dit qu' il faut faire un 38
alors regardez je vous montrais après
l'épreuve qu'on a mais vous vous dites
que c'est grosso fob dit me mohamed ben
il suffit de regarder l'émission de se
regarder les miss la miss actuelle on a
dit qu'elle avait des formes donc c'est
extraordinaire moi je trouve qu'elle a
encore tout à fait normal c'est pas des
formes et on a le droit d'être blonde
brune rousse peu importe devenir du nord
du sud mais être un peu enrobée de
groban ans ça ne passe pas mais ce à
l'image de la société c'est pas que miss
france c'est comme ça vous regardez les
présentatrice de jt vous regardez dans
les émissions un homme qui est gros
c'est un bon vivant
une femme qui est gros sel se néglige
est le problème il est là c'est la
distinction entre le traitement des
femmes et le traitement des hommes le
problème c'est que dans la société ça a
un impact
demain les gens seront discriminer le
sont actuellement lorsqu'ils sont un peu
trop gros et les gros et les obèses
comme on les appelle ils n'ont
d'existence aux yeux des autres que pour
perdre du poids et je pense que cette
image qu'on donne de la femme correspond
à stéréotypes que les gens vont avoir
dans la tête et que désormais les
petites filles et on se dira zoug des
magazines des photos qui sont
photoshopée l es una télé et voit que
des personnes minces maigre ça pose pas
de problème et lorsqu'on parle de vraies
femmes parce que la vraie femme ne fait
pas du 36 elle fait du 42 ou du 44 et
ben disparaît de l'écran et c'est ça le
problème
alors vous vous avez un truc est assez
curieux c'est que vous êtes déterminé
deuxième wii concours de miss auvergne
ils ont pris la 3è non sélectionnés
troisième conduisait le car ne rien
annoncer sa miss votre compte bien c'est
à dire mais par 60 à lever le camp de m
ils ont pris la 3è mais pas la deuxième
fait ou pas ce que parce que quand
sylvie tellier dit haut et fort que je
n'ai pas été élue du public c'est faux
moi ma place de première dauphine je les
ai pas volées et je pense que quand on
est sur scène et quand on entend la
police des applaudissements du public
ben ça ça fait chaud au coeur et ça
prouve que les gens les aiment le
changement et ça elle n'assume pas en
fait clairement elle assume par et moi
je suis aussi vous répondre j'ai mon
droit de réponse et je le dis
aujourd'hui très bien mondino alors
vous dites non et oui évidemment que moi
je constate du tout que comme utiles
soient vos sauts fable mais jimmy waite
est très sympa tu les vrais fans ne faut
pas eu 36 ya des vraies femmes qui font
du 36 sein même du trône cas du 38 du
carnaval les abeilles a pas de fausse
femme il ya des classes moyennes tout
l'air d'un gars d'arrêter mes sens si tu
veut révolutionner du jour là les canons
de beauté tels qu'ils existent depuis 57
ans on peut reprocher qui est pas plus
une diversité mais les canons de beauté
à l'international
c'est pas c'est pas un syndrome français
voilà dans le monde entier les femmes
sauf filiforme cepeda que les autres ne
sont pas belles ça veut dire que vous
représentez la france l'image qu'on a
des françaises on réclame une certaine
certaine forme mais moi je suis pas là
jamais senti qu'une file avec jean
michel vous dites que le comité miss
france n'est pas grosse pomme alors je
vous dis moi je veux montrer des preuves
puisque amandine s'est présenté deux
fois donc à des concours et d'un accès à
l'élection miss france est al constate à
chaque fois son tour de taille est un
frein alors amandine et se présente au
concours régional en mai 2016 pour est
élue miss auvergne
elle reçoit ensuite un mail de jean
jacques sabourin président du comité
auvergne centre val de loire qui lui
indique qu'il faudrait qu'elles
atteignent une taille 38 pour l'élection
qui a lieu en octobre
en fait le maximum pour arriver à une
taille 38 et tout ira bien
je le pense noyer ou pas vous avez
délégué centre val de loire et
d'auvergne pour le comité il sera au top
2016 une selon elle elle échoue donc à
l'élection et de région car elle ne fait
pas une taille 38 cents à 40 mars 2019
amandine est invité par jean jacques ça
- toujours à participer à un autre au
concours miss volcans d'auvergne
il lui fallut que c'est l'occasion de
renouer avec l'élection
regardez ce que l'uni gens là coco
amandine j'espère que tu vas bien tu
avais peut-être vu que je faisais une
nouvelle élection d'ailleurs puisque
c'est une des portes erdal voilà il
assez sympa d'ailleurs un jean jacques à
joigny sympa quand il est très gentil
jour la nuit et il lui explique que
c'est l'occasion de renouer avec les
élections
elle est élue première dauphine de miss
volcans d'auvergne elle peut donc se
présenter au concours régional qui est
la dernière étape mais vous dit vous
êtes éliminé donc là le lendemain
amandine est mystérieusement évincé de
la compétition régionale par le jury
sans plus d'explications regardez le
mail qu'elle a reçu amandine donc voilà
donc elle n'a pas été prise alors que la
1ère et la 3e 3e ont été prises et pas
vous voilà donc c'est assez assez
curieux passé car oui c'est ce concours
évoluera le jour dans tous les boues
seront représentés génial non c'est pas
vrai tu as tort jean-michel j'ai rien
dit non quand tu dis que là la française
moyenne et filiforme c'est faux je veux
dire le tour de taille n'est pas 38 le
tour de taille moyen on m'a viré de
cacher des chutes attend ensuite qu'on
oublie de dire c'est que ce qu'on
pourrait totalement discriminatoire
n'est pas seulement pour la taille mais
aussi on utilise célibataire il ya vous
avez même s'il ya derrière
il faut être célibataire pas pacsés pas
divorcés n'ont pas d'enfants et même pas
veuve vous pouvez me dire cette fois le
problème c'est hors sujet monsieur
carrière merci cependant mais je vais
vous dire on est en ligne
on est en ligne avec terrain qui
s'appelle leila malhomme elle est
organisatrice du concours miss haute
loire et cantal pour le comité miss
france et va nous dire ce soir qu'elle
décide de claquer la porte de miss
france car elle ne se reconnaît plus
dans les valeurs morales du concours
bonsoir leïla ben ali
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous
soutenez amandine bio et vous dites que
le concours miss france est grosso fob
je ne dis pas que les grosses trop fort
parce que je suis pas de réponse directe
mais les actes montrent le contraire
donc voilà donc vous pensé voilà donc il
faut vraiment faire un premier but pour
pouvoir se présenter en escompte bain à
mon sens où si oui
vous dites vous dites que c'est c'est
dire que sylvie tellier n'est pas une
bonne patronne du comité miss france
pourquoi ne la connais pas je peux pas
la juger malheureusement oui mais ce que
j'entends d'après ce que j'entends
mais pourquoi vous avez décidé de
claquer la porte du dudu du comité miss
france vous un tout simplement pour
faciliter la tâche à mon délégué parce
que je ne dois pas rentrer dans les
critères non plus deux pour être
organisatrice de l'élection parce qu'on
n'avait pas les mêmes valeurs morales et
pour moi c'est toi les malheurs qui vous
déranger mais les valeurs qu'on me
dérange quand on en fait espérer un
jeune fille quand le vide donne de
l'espoir pour au final des bières non au
revoir d'accord alors voilà donc quoi
c'est que c'est par rapport à la taille
eux qui sont bien de dire d'hier
l'instant oui donc c'est ça qui vous
dérange le plus c'est le cas c'est le
cas d'amandine est d'accord d'accord
merci là il ad'abord est avec nous et
merci mon témoignage de l'intérieur
merci
leïla
on avoir l'avis de tagab lors de son
discours de présentation by malama
chavez donc la miss france actuelle a
lancé un message d'espoir pour les
jeunes femmes rondes pourtant regardez
festival malama chavez j'ai 24 ans j'ai
longtemps été vendus et c'est quelque
chose qui me tient à coeur de partager
aujourd'hui j'ai confiance en moi et je
m'accepte il y à la portée de tous de
faire pareil alors si je peux être
porteuses d'espoir c'est avec grand
plaisir que je le ferai merci cette
histoire de grandes photos de miss
france ça on en parle beaucoup puisque
mission en 2019
elle n'a pas arrêté de dire elle
n'hésite pas à répondre aux détracteurs
qui la critique sur ses rondeurs où son
amour de la bonne bouffe et c'est vrai
que c'est un truc qui revient devant
très souvent oui vraiment où c'est le
plus bel exemple je veux pas dire son
nom puisque j'y arriverai pas bel
exemple pascal elle était un peu rondes
et ils ont ils nous ont dit il faut que
tu aies maigri alors elle a maigri aller
pour ne pas être mais pas se présenter
un peu plus ronde pour que ce qu'elle
est et non pas parce qu'ils veulent
passer c'est l'exemple qu'on y amandine
moi ça me dérangerait pas clairement dit
naomi seront jeu m'a bouleversée
d'allemand et manifs et et leurs trucs
dans la meute soixante dix mois 1 m 68
je prends aussi et si vous demandez
il ya des moments dans le public sur les
200 personnes qui fait du 36 personnes
va le verbe
des personnes votent mr public plupart
des françaises a fondu 40 carnet est
évidemment que miss france est grosso
fab évidemment que tous les combats eux
de beauté sont grosso femmes étant donné
que les femmes rondes sont exclues de
ces concours il ya carrément des
concours qui s'appelle miss ronde me
louise grande taille ont laissé quand on
leur fait leur concours à elle parce
qu'elles ne participent elles ne peuvent
pas participer au concours médium au
concours grand public au concours de
miss france au grand concours nationaux
elles sont exclues parce qu'elles ne
répondent pas à ces critères de beauté
figée qui ne représente pas du tout la
femme d'aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment
amandine est ce que vous êtes posé la
question au moment de vous dire je vais
suivre et les critères et je vais
essayer douala de perdre deux tailles
pour pouvoir me présenter en 2016
effectivement en 2016 en jeu ouais c'est
qu'un en 2016 mois là j'étais quand même
tu peux plus jeune et je connaissais pas
tout ça d'accord n'essaie pas et j'ai
posé la question et on présentait donc
je ne connaissais pas les critères et
c'est donc c'est là où on a ou j'ai reçu
ce mail justement et c'est effectivement
ça m'a effleuré l'esprit
alors mais samassa main je me suis posé
la question je m'en restait comme vous
avez pas besoin d'être miss france il a
déjà mis ses pmp c'est déjà beaucoup
victor nuit 65% un autre à 35% voilà
donc les gens sont claro d'accord avec
cette partie là d'